[Musique]
je m'appelle gotti grondin j'ai 27 ans
je suis propriétaire d'une boulangerie
saint philippe qui s'appelle la cave
gourmande
j'ai passé mon cmp pâtissier à sainte
clotilde suite à l'obtention de ce ca
fait je me suis dirigé vers la métropole
à paris exactement j'ai eu la chance de
côtoyer de très grands chefs disant
intensifs
je suis revenu à l'île de la réunion
pour ouvert ma boulangerie pâtisserie
pour la création de mon entreprise était
accompagné par la d2r puisqu'on est un
énorme coup de pouce notamment sur les
fonds qu on n'avait aucun fonds pour
l'entreprise c'est donc du coup nous ont
permis à travers le tage d'obtenir 8000
euros de subventions ce qui nous a
énormément aidés pour l'ouverture
d'entreprise alors la cave gourmande a
été créée en octobre 2010 est donc on
est actuellement trois employés et
en apprentis ont proposent des
viennoiseries
jour fraîche des pâtisseries artisanales
entièrement artisanal fabriqué de a à z
sur place et du pain traditionnel des
baguettes tout ce qu'il ya de plus
simple c'est un chemin de vie celle
aventure d'une nuit à chaque instant
même quand on n'est pas dans les locaux
de la boulangerie on va démarcher des
hôtels on va démarcher des restaurants
vont enfin on s'arrête jamais
[Musique]
ouvert la première boutique sur la
commune de mare longue à saint philippe
au bout d'un an et demi on l'a eu
l'opportunité de déménager dans le
centre-ville de saint philippe on a
manqué les murs nous mêmes on a fait la
plomberie qu'on a fait la peinture nous
mêmes on a posé des carreaux on a
vraiment créé une boulangerie pâtisserie
à partir de rien pour en termes de
chiffre d'affaires on est du simple au
double en six mois on l'a vu on a doublé
la clientèle ont trahi notamment avec
les restaurants les hôtels les auberges
les gîtes beaucoup et le tourisme
énormément les locaux aussi en soi mais
une grosse clientèle de saint philippe
voilà pour moi la vraie performance et
de prendre un produit noble comme la
vanille qui est un produit exceptionnel
surtout celle de saint philippe et
pouvoir l'a transformé sans l'altérer
pour créer ma tarte à la vanille je vais
chercher directement chez le producteur
me gousse de vanille qui sont
sélectionnés par un producteur ce qui me
permet moins d'avoir un produit sur la
finalité qui est exceptionnel
[Musique]
l'aco pied du mur qu'on voit si on est
aussi fort contre l'europe
[Musique]
je m'appelle thibault au club al kini
j'ai 26 ans et je suis l'un des
créateurs de la brasserie dalons
brasserie de bières artisanales sur les
hauteurs de saint denis sur la colline
des camélias
alors on s'est rencontrés à l'école de
commerce de montpellier on a fait un
master en création d'entreprise là bas
on était ensuite au chômage
donc on s'est dit pour créer notre
propre emploi autant créer notre
entreprise l'idée on buvait une bière
dans un bar avec ce matin et on s'est
dit c'est verizon dix poules ils ont les
écouter de la bonne musique
pourquoi pas faire de la bière et la
sonate et on dit ça tombe bien j'ai un
garage à saint-denis j'en fais rien et
on s'est formée et puis on est venu
faire de la bière dans le garage
on a vu qu'il y avait un marché
potentiel sur la réunion et peu de
concurrents directs on a été aidé alors
dans un premier temps parfois d'emploi
pour l'indemnité chômage puisque on est
au chômage dans la création puis après
on a demandé
le taz on a reçu le tage on a travaillé
avec la chambre des métiers et la dge et
jonathan a fait un livre un microcrédit
à la vie alors d'annoncer quoi c'est une
aventure humaine de copains on a une
force c'est la complémentarité des pères
dans le sens où en fait on est 3 1 qui
est commercial un qui fait la production
et un autre qui est sûr le financent
donc on produit de la bière on essaye au
maximum d'incorporer des produits locaux
dans notre bière on met du gingembre
dans la blanche on met de la vanille
dans l'aude tout on a fait des bières à
la mangue de bière la betterave qu'en
fait on essaye via un autre brassage et
une communication de promouvoir au
maximum toute la richesse en fait le
terroir de linky est ultra riches pour
pour la production artisanale quoi alors
on est performant dans la mesure où on a
réussi à transformer ce garage en réel
société la performance
au niveau qualité qualitatif ou la bière
à une stabilité dans le doubs sur la
durée ensuite au niveau commercial
puisqu'on a réussi à accroître une
centaine de points de vente et en moins
d'un an on a
on est cool maintenant on produit 9
litres par mois et aussi au niveau
financier puisque on arrive à réinvestir
en autofinancement dans des nouvelles qu
un nouvel outil de pour livrer une
voiture et un nouvel outil de production
sans ballon performance ni durable ni
honorable la finale a eu lieu dans le
jardin de la villa du département
la boulangerie de saint joseph a été
récompensé à travers la victoire de
gauthier grondin de la sas la cave
gourmande dans la catégorie performance
[Musique]